I do the boo thing a lot hi my queen
lily ponds damn Queen well you've earned
it
because you've dabbled in so many fields
and the latest makeup which is so
incredible congratulations on your
collab with tart tell me all about it
uh well it's a club that I did we
started a year ago and you know I'm
somehow there's someone that I don't
know how to do my makeup I'm not like an
expert like you know I have so many
people that I admire so many friends
that do makeup everything better I'm
someone that have always struggled I
don't know what to play what's the best
thing for me to like wear what will make
me look you know good yes yes so just
like well why don't I make one of my own
that's gonna help me like for example I
wanted to do like of the look that I
always doing I would always tell my and
makeup artists like what is this doing
cuz I like this once I describe it yeah
so he helped me create my own look this
is what I usually what I didn't know and
this is what I usually wear all the time
and it's now it's like so easy so if you
get this palette you will literally have
the signature Lele look I mean if you
get this palette it's gonna be like a go
going out look a daytime look and it's
just like if you want to be simple as
well you know a like anybody who uses
this you're gonna look like you know how
to do your makeup 100% well I think it's
cool that there are some warden like
neutral tones in there you can of course
glam it up with some of that it's like
all these are like like all like simple
and then it comes like this one BAM just
in this one in this Yin so I think I
want to do it like a book o said of this
way I want to do it like a book
so you're creative in always the
packaging you had a hand in all of it
then I wanted to do I like bit of marble
yeah wonderful and one of my favorite
colors after red is purple purple of
course who is your ultimate beauty icon
like when your beauty icon when you're
getting ready
is there someone you're channeling or
thinking of when you're getting your
makeup put on I mean if you if you're
talking about like friends that I like
the people like that I like how they do
their makeup sure or celebrities or
singers or any weapons or singers I
think I like a lot of India where she
does her makeup why do you like zendaya
she just goes full-on and I like um
how'd it was new for you oh yeah well
that's all about the sparkle it er I
like that but I like I like simple
makeup too you know i like like
Hadiya when she does her makeup every
single person I mean everybody's a pro
you know I don't really I don't really
have a favorite at all so I think I mean
you know what I liked a lot don't leap
on when she does her makeup sick right a
simple have you met Dewar have you met
Gigi's and daya I've not do us she's
really nice I met her I mean I would die
for a Layla do its collapse oh my god
what oh my god Thanks okay I mean I
would like to collab with Shakira that's
for sure
well let's just put it out there I mean
yes I hope Shakira is a fan of
Entertainment Tonight do you want to
tell her why she should collab with you
because she knows he knows how obsessed
I am with her she knows he already met
her I love you so much
check her out I would love to collab in
any way I'll do your makeup I can't but
oh sure there's the end I'll tell you
what to do you can you have your own
packaging I can but I've just super
nervous today well so I know you're not
originally from Miami but you used to
live in Miami yeah and the Super Bowl is
in Miami this year wait you you know
that I'm right well I need to know
everything oh I don't I have I have my
friends that are going I know who is
like in charge I talked I know a lot of
people are going I know how I know how
to get there okay okay but the question
is do you know how to get to Shakira of
course okay so what's the plan are you
gonna come out on stage are you gonna be
a dancer I'm not gonna be on sweet but I
would definitely i'll definitely like
try to see her before or something or
anywhere like it wherever she goes to
dinner oh no I don't know so so after
you met her and you had that like really
tender sweet moment where you just kind
of like burst into tears have you formed
a friendship has she sort of been like a
mentor to you no no no I wanted to keep
it like that you know like it just
sometimes it's hard to become like you
see her so high it's hard to become like
friends with someone like that could I
be very nervous but I feel like she
exceeded your expectations Oh a hundred
percent yeah yeah she was she was it she
was amazing what did you guys talk about
Oh me yeah she was basically the whole
time being like don't cry don't card
okay and I was just like I'm not crying
I'm not crying don't worry about it but
I was saying so did you do your
impression for her no I can't she's the
best at it it looks so bad doing it your
impression is flawless and phenomenal
will you show our cameras which
impression of what Oh wherever whenever
whatever whatever you feel most oh let's
see I'm really bad with like you know
not as good at her as her okay but my
friend does it with me all the time
Sandra Oh what is it see to her
sure alright so I do I do the boob thing
a lot and then like the video yeah just
like the video and then I do
let's manifest it let's get a little a
Shakira collab in 2020 do it make it you
speaking of music you've you've put out
some some bangers and your fans love it
and I have to tell you we want more so
are you working on more my favorite one
is coming out really yeah okay is it
gonna be similar to say low so yeah the
thing is like selasa was the only single
I've had of me alone the others I've had
a sound with people I think so those was
the only one I've done alone so this is
the next one is the second one that I'm
ever gonna do solo
is it a departure for you is it
different it's very different you're
gonna see our very mature Lily very very
not not like not though this does the
Lydia you always see that she like jokes
around this is very serious it's a very
serious story for me is it a ballad
no it's just like of course you can okay
how is it badass I mean is it is it
sexier is it more vamped up it has a
brave brave message it's better because
of the message is that us because you
can see the attitude there you can see
the rage though anger I have and what
are you angry about talk about your CD
and it is emotional for you to put this
song out is it an emotion it was it was
emotional for me because I know my
background but it was I loved it because
it actually is not only about me it's
about like woman it's a lot about
I think obviously I will never stop
doing like social media but I think when
it comes to music I have to show a side
that it's a little bit more you know
it's a good sense personal yeah and I
think my friends are gonna like that
they're gonna see oh this is a you
always have to like evolved I feel like
with music I should evolve and I should
show another side of myself you know
sometimes we're serious and so you're
mature and sometimes you're silly like
what I am every time you're an artist
but I mean the way that you were teasing
your music it was it hard for you to
write a song about something so
heartbreaking my first I went to you I
think when people see it you think my
fans will if they see the music video or
they see the song they'll probably know
or you'll know also by that what what
it's about
you've dominated music comedy social
media now make up what is left on the
lip on this bucket list
what are you dying to try next me I
would love to direct a feature film are
you pursuing that are you taking steps
toward oh yeah I want to do that a lot
direct oh yeah
is there a dream movie or or actors
there's not a copy of someone that I
would love to even make see in action
one day you've got so many things on
your plate you're one of the busiest
women in Hollywood right now do you even
have time for a personal life um no
really no because I no no I mean yes yes
but no what does that mean because yes I
could but no I decided not to because I
kinda always want to work I love working
that's the thing oh well that is 1000%
I'm so that right there with you yeah um
I believe that when someone comes into
your life they should compliment it you
know yes be there to like lift you up so
can you set the record straight
are you seeing anyone right now nope
you're single girl single you will know
when well there's someone I'd like but I
was like I can't say we're together or
not like I'm the kind of person then who
is this who's this mystery man no I
don't even know yet
just even from afar but it's just like
as a thing it's like I fall in love very
quickly but I also fall out of love very
quickly too
okay so what does the next suitor who's
lucky enough to get your attention what
does he have to do to be successful to
be successful yeah I think I have to
first he has to make me laugh
it can't be all about the physical stuff
for me yes even emotionally I have to
get attached to him like for example
like you have to make me laugh he has to
be like someone ambitious someone that
I'd like my err yeah someone that has a
lot of values it's a family person and
do you think it needs to be someone who
always does it need to be someone who is
in a similar line of work as you because
I know your schedule is so crazy I've
never had a boyfriend that has been in
the same line as me so you've never
dated a guy in entertainment no oh wow
your fans seem to think a lot of guys
you collab with but there could be
something going on Bob with right but
nobody that's like in my level like I'm
doing stuff like this no I've had and
also I date people that are outside of
America I don't know why I do that oh
well do you have a celebrity crush which
I don't you can see his face your phone
screen is his face no I have my phone oh
yeah okay sorry who is sliding in your
DMS right now is there like fun is there
a collab whether it's romantic or
whether it's career-oriented who's
sliding into my DM yeah but I don't say
like you know I don't really talk about
it because like it there's just a
difference different stuff but you know
youtubers and people for even I've met a
lot of people from makeup since your
makeup right now dancers a lot really
yes okay it just one name come to mind
of like something that you can tease a
project that's in the works you know
what the guy that did scooby-doo Papa
yeah wants to do something with me
because I helped that song could become
very very very popular with the video
that I did with one of my friends and
after that video like it blew up cuz it
was actually it was like before blew up
it was already out for like a year ago
and then I heard it I was like well this
song is cool and the video like God like
30mins you learn it yeah and explode
and everybody was like doing the squeeze
of a fast food and he even did a song
for me saying like Thank You Lily for
actually making this song be big he was
like always grateful so I love it I have
a question for you would you ever
consider being the Bachelorette having
your love life on TV for the whole world
to weigh in and watch I love
entertainment yeah sure would you yeah
putting it all out there yeah but then
I'll probably legs dump them
well you don't love me leave as a knight
and I get over there I'm not I'm
maturing up in when it comes to that
well you're 23 you're really young yeah
where do you see yourself at 30 I wish I
could have like maybe two kids yeah yeah
I want to have a family being as
well-known as you are I mean you've got
hundreds of millions of fans around the
world does it ever get hard for you just
in your daily life people always coming
up to you your phone always buzzing do
you ever just wish you could have like
five minutes of just kind of turning it
off for a second of course yeah yeah I
feel like it's so I turn my phone off a
lot actually the end it's very important
because I need to be grounded in the
beginning I remember in the beginning
when this all started I wasn't and and
that was my biggest mistake I started
being not grounded and like thinking
that was on top of the world and that's
not true and I stopped doing that and
it's been I've been so like dedicated to
myself in my health was there something
that that happened that really kind of
even my friends or my family saying like
hey you're not present in Italy even
like those people that are telling me
that I'm like no and then you slowly
start seeing that you missed out on many
things because you were so much on your
phone that's when you know so are you in
touch with your girl Camilla Kibeho yes
I'm gonna see her I think tomorrow are
you yes oh so you're still friends yes
like are you gonna work on a collab oh I
don't I don't know yeah but I know for a
fact that there's a video there's a
she's probably gonna do a little cameo
in my music video into in a second like
in a little bit more I love that how
happy are you to see her so in love I
it's so funny because we talked about it
one time and she was sake we're talking
about how our love life might sucked and
she didn't have anything
you know either and to see her with this
guy that I had a feeling she really
liked oh you knew yeah I felt it I'm not
saying I knew but I felt it very much
and I feel like he always loved her as
well I think that she deserves and I
know for a fact her mom loves loves them
together as well do you think he's the
one I think I hope I mean I can't say
he's the one but but I hope he is
because they are so cute together and
they really look in love you really do I
love it congratulations
thank you
[Music]